PICKING UP AN INCREASING SHARE
OF THE MENTIONS.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT HE'S WELL
AHEAD BUT HE'S GAINING.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT TRUMP WANTS
TO CROWD OUT THE COMPETITION AND
MAINTAIN THE POLL NUMBERS THAT
HE CURRENTLY HAS.
>> HARRY ENTEN, GREAT STUFF AS
ALWAYS.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> SOURCES TELL CNN DONALD
TRUMP IS ASKING A FEDERAL COURT
TO BLOCK HIS FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT, MIKE PENCE, FROM
TESTIFYING BEFORE A GRAND JURY
ABOUT JANUARY 6th AND THE
EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S 2020 ELECTION LOSS.
THAT IS PART OF A NEW FILING
SUBMITTED SECRETLY IN A SEALED
PROCEEDING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT WITH
JEREMY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, JIM.
BASICALLY THIS WILL MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR SPECIAL COUNSEL,
JACK SMITH, TO OBTAIN TESTIMONY
FROM VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
OF COURSE THIS INVESTIGATION IS
PLAYING OUT AS WE SEE IN THE
COURSE OF THIS 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
RACE.
NOW, THE FILING AS YOU SAID, IT
WAS FILED UNDER SEAL AND SO WOE
DON'T KNOW DETAILS ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC ARGUMENT THAT THE TRUMP
LEGAL TEAM IS MAKING.
WHAT WE'RE TOLD IS FROM SOURCES
THAT THEY ARE BASICALLY TRYING
TO PREVENT PENCE FROM TESTIFYING
ABOUT CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION.
AND THIS ISN'T THE ONLY
ROADBLOCK THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS FACING, BECAUSE PENCE
HIMSELF HAS SAID THAT HE PLANS
TO FIGHT THE SUBPOENA FOR A
DIFFERENT REASON.
PENCE HAS ARGUED THAT HE IS
PROTECTED BY THE CONSTITUTION'S
SPEECH AND DEBATE CLAUSE WHICH
SHIELDS THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
FROM CERTAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION.
HE SAYS BECAUSE HE WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE ON
JANUARY 6 WHEN HE WAS CERTIFYING
THE VOTES THAT HE IS PROTECTED
UNDER THIS CLAUSE.
NOW, WHAT THE KEY HERE IS GOING
TO BE, HOW MUCH TIME IS THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL GOING TO TAKE TO
TRY TO FIGHT THESE BATTLES ORs
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL GOING TO
DECIDE THAT HE HAS ENOUGH
EVIDENCE TO TRY TO WRAP UP THIS
INVESTIGATION, POTENTIALLY
BEFORE THESE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
AND OTHER MATTERS ARE RESOLVED,
JIM.
>> ALL RIGHT, JEREMY HERB, A
VERY IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
MORE NOW WITH ELIE HONIG.
HIS NEW BOOK IT "UNTOUCHABLE,
HOW POWERFUL PEOPLE GET AWAY
WITH IT."
I FEEL LIKE THAT TITLE IS THE
PERFECT SEGUE TO WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT TRUMP IS
NOW DOING WITH EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
PUT ASIDE THE FACT THAT HE'S NOW
ON THE SAME PAGE, PRETTY MUCH,
AS MIKE PENCE, HIS FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT, THAT THEY BOTH DON'T
WANT HIM TO TESTIFY, OR AT LEAST
THAT'S THE WAY PENCE IS PUTTING
IT OUT THERE PUBLICLY, COULD
THIS WORK?
HE'S NOT PRESIDENT ANYMORE.
>> JIM, YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS UNUSUAL TO SEE TRUMP AND
PENCE REUNITED, I SUPPOSE.
I THINK IT'S VERY MUCH OF A LONG
SHOT.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP HAS A
STEEP, ROCKY, UPHILL CLIMB
LEGALLY.
HE'S INVOKING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
MEANING I HAD CONVERSATIONS WHEN
I WAS PRESIDENT WITH ONE OF MY
KEY ADVISERS, MY VICE PRESIDENT,
THAT NEEDS TO REMAIN SECRET.
HE'S GOT TWO BIG PROBLEMS.
ONE, DONALD TRUMP IS NOW A
FORMER PRESIDENT.
WHILE IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR A
FORMER PRESIDENT TO INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, THE COURTS
HAVE SAID IT'S MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR A FORMER PRESIDENT
THAN A SITTING PRESIDENT.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
THE OTHER PROBLEM DONALD TRUMP
HAS IS THIS IS A CRIMINAL GRAND
JURY SUBPOENA.
USUALLY COURTS ARE GOING TO
HONOR CRIMINAL GRAND JURY
SUBPOENAS.
TYPICALLY WITH SOME EXCEPTIONS,
BUT TYPICALLY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE DOES THAT PREVAIL OVER
A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA.
SO IT'S A SHOT IN THE DARK HERE.
I THINK IT'S GOT A CHANCE OF
SUCCEEDING BUT ONLY A VERY LONG
SHOT CHANCE HERE.
>> AND, ELIE, PENCE IS ALREADY
TRYING TO AVOID TESTIFYING
CLAIMING IT WOULD BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL UNDER THE
SPEECH OR DEBATE CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
IS HE RIGHT ABOUT THAT?
WHAT ARE THE ODDS OF THAT BEING
SUCCESSFUL?
I'VE BEEN WONDERING ABOUT THIS
ONE.
>> HE'S GOT A LITTLE BIT OF A
BETTER ARGUMENT HERE AND I THINK
HE COULD SUCCEED IN SOME PART.
HIS ARGUMENT IS THAT IN MY ROLE
AS VICE PRESIDENT, I WAS ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE AND THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS CANNOT BE FORCED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS OUTSIDE OF
CONGRESS ITSELF.
I DO THINK THE COURT WILL SAY,
IT CAN APPLY TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
YOU SORT OF HAVE TO GO QUESTION
BY QUESTION AND ASK IS THIS
WITHIN HIS PROPER LEGISLATIVE
DUTIES?
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED WITH
REPRESENTATIVE PERRY AND LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
THE COURTS SAID ONLY A VERY
NARROW SUBSECTION OF YOUR
TESTIMONY IS PROTECTED.
THAT WHICH APPLIES TO ACTUAL
LEGITIMATE CONGRESSIONAL DUTIES.
ALL THE OTHER STUFF IS IN PLAY
AND I THINK WE'LL GET A SIMILAR
RESPONSE HERE WITH MIKE PENCE.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE DELAY
TACTICS ON THE PART OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
A GAZILLION TIMES, THIS IS WHAT
HE DOES.
DOESN'T THIS COMPLICATE MATTERS,
THOUGH, FOR THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
JACK SMITH, IF TRUMP AND PENCE
CAN CONTINUE TO JUST LAY OUT ONE
DELAY TACTIC AFTER ANOTHER TO
THE POINT, AND ELIE, THIS IS THE
BIG QUESTION I HAVE IN MY MIND.
MIGHT YOU HAVE A POSSIBILITY, A
SCENARIO IN WHICH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS INDICTED WHILE
WE'RE IN THE THICK OF A
RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN WHERE YOU
HAVE JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCING HE'S
RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION AND
WE'RE JUST INTO THE CAMPAIGN
SEASON, BECAUSE IT'S TAKEN THIS
LONG IT DOES HAVE THAT SORT OF I
DON'T WANT TO SAY CLOUD OVER IT,
BUT IT BECOMES MORE COMPLICATED.
>> I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT, JIM.
AS YOU SAY WE TALK ABOUT THIS A
LOT.
WE ARE TWO YEARS AND TWO MONTHS
OUT FROM JANUARY 6th AT THIS
POINT.
THE PROBLEM THAT JACK SMITH HAS
INHERITED NOW, ALL THAT TIME
WASTED IS GONE.
IF HE'S GOING TO FIGHT THIS
FIGHT OVER THIS SUBPOENA TO MIKE
PENCE, HE'S GOT TO BEAT BOTH
ARGUMENTS, TRUMP'S ARGUMENT AND
PENCE'S ARGUMENT.
WE'VE GOT TO GO THROUGH THE
DISTRICT COURT WHERE WE ARE NOW,
THROUGH THE COURT OF APPEALS AND
WHOEVER LOSES THERE WILL TRY TO
GET IT TO THE SUPREME COURT.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT MONTHS OF
DELAY.
DOES JACK SMITH HAVE THAT LUXURY
TO WAIT THAT LONG?
COULD WE SEE DONALD TRUMP
INDICTED AND IT LANDED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ELECTORAL
CAMPAIGN?
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT COULD COME OUT OF FULTON
COUNTY.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT
INVESTIGATION.
LOOK, JACK SMITH IS OPERATING
FROM A DISADVANTAGED POSITION
HERE BECAUSE MERRICK GARLAND
WASTED ABOUT TWO YEARS AND SO
HE'S GOT TO DO A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS, IS IT WORTH TAKING
THIS LONG TO FIGHT TO GET MIKE
PENCE'S TESTIMONY.
>> WHICH LEADS ME TO THE
QUESTION, ELIE, IS THERE A POINT
ON THE CALENDAR THAT YOU THINK,
OKAY, IT JUST BECOMES DIFFICULT
TO PURSUE THE CASE ANYMORE AND
TRUMP HAS SUCCEEDED IN RUNNING
OUT THE CLOCK AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE TO FACE
THAT CRITICISM FROM A LOT OF
AMERICANS THAT THEY JUST
DILLYDALLIED TOO LONG, THEY JUST
TOOK TOO LONG?
>> AS A TECHNICAL LEGAL MATTER
THEY'RE STILL IN THEIR RIGHTS TO
BRING THIS CASE.
I THINK THERE DOES COME A POINT,
LIKE I SAID, TWO YEARS, TWO
MONTHS OUT FROM JANUARY 6.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON IN ANY
POSITION OF OFFICIAL POWER HAS
BEEN CHARGED WITH ANYTHING AND
EVERYONE IS SO FOCUSED ON
INDICTMENT.
LOOK, I WAS A PROSECUTOR.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT TRIAL.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO TRY THIS
CASE?
WE'RE JUST GETTING A PREVIEW OF
ALL THE APPEALS AND MOTIONS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET TO